Speaker 1: Hey, let's take a break from all
of the politics for a moment.
Let's do something completely different.
Okay.
I got an email from Chris.
Chris with a K, by the way, which we're going
to put up on the screen.
And Chris said, Hey, David, I know you aren't
a self-help guy, but you seem to have some
good habits.
Can you list the easiest and simplest ways
to improve health and well-being that you've
come across?
Well, listen, Chris is 100% right.
I am not a self-help guy.
I'm not going to be here to tell you about
lobsters cleaning their room or whatever it
is that Jordan Peterson is going to advise
you.
I will give you what I think are just some
really low hanging fruit that most people
can do.
That, in my experience, will put you you know,
there's this kind of 8020 rule, right?
There's people out there looking for the exact
supplements and what's the right number of
reps to squeeze into a 14 minute workout for
maximum gain.
And then what about, you know, taking apple
cider vinegar with lemon and and, you know,
bathing in blue light or not blue light in
order to sleep right there.
You can try to get to the 99%.
But very often 8020 is where you want to be.
And there are some really simple things that
will get you like 80% of the benefit of a
lot of this stuff.
So this is just my opinion.
I'm not a self-help guy, but here's just a
few things that I would say.
First of all, walk 8000 steps a day.
If you can make it 10,000 even better.
You don't know how much you're walking.
Most phones have a step tracker in them.
I use a Fitbit that goes on my wrist.
If you're walking 8000 steps a day every day,
that is already going to put you in terms
of mobility and avoiding sort of like a sedentary
situation.
It's going to put you ahead of 80% of people.
If I look down, if it's 6:00 or 7:00 and I
look down and I've only walked five or 6000
steps, I will just exit my house.
If I have to do it after dinner, when the
baby's sleeping and just walk for 15 minutes
to get to my 8000 steps, I will do it.
And I've been doing this for years.
That alone is going to give you this 80% benefit.
With something that's super simple in terms
of diet, people will go and they'll say, Oh,
I need what's the right type of oil now?
There's this whole A.C. oil thing that's going
on, but it's already been debunked.
And what about what about keto and all this?
All the.
Okay.
For me, the simplest shorthand to eating what
is probably a pretty good diet is to focus
on getting 3030 grams of fiber in your diet
per day.
How is this possible?
How could that do so much?
I think here's the reason why foods that are
high in fiber number one tend to be less processed.
Number two, they tend to be lower in saturated
fat, although some of them have high good
fats.
If you are prioritizing 30 grams of fiber
per day, you're probably eating a relatively
healthy diet just because of the foods that
have fiber.
Okay.
So I know that there is a million diets and
then people are finding a diet that's completely
unsustainable.
This that, the other thing.
Oh, you know, now I'm on blueberries.
No, now I'm on opposite or okay, if you focus
on just trying to get 30 grams of fiber per
day, you are already going to be ahead of
80% of the American population.
Number three, drink enough water.
I find sometimes at 5:00 I am not feeling
well and I'll think, oh my goodness, is it
the virus?
What is happening here?
And then I'll realize I went to the gym at
two.
I then had a meeting at a cafe where I had
a coffee and no water.
I haven't had water since lunch and I worked
out and it's 530, I will have a glass of water
and I will feel better very quickly.
Drink enough water.
I wake up in the morning, You know how you
bring that glass of water to your nightstand
and then you never drink it?
The goal for me is I wake up and I have it
in the morning, so drinking enough water are
very, very important.
Protect your sleep schedule at least five
nights a week.
Okay?
And by that, I mean, if you know how much
sleep you need to feel pretty good, make sure
that your schedule allows you that sleeping
schedule at least five nights a week.
I try to go with at least six nights a week.
If you need 7 hours and 45 minutes, then you
got to figure out how to get there.
How do you eke out enough time to be in bed
and able to sleep that amount of time?
And then lastly, read every day, what's the
deal with this reading?
What what am I talking about?
I'm talking about reading physical books,
fiction or nonfiction, whatever you want.
I read nonfiction during the day.
Fiction at night.
If you are reading some number of pages every
single day and it's useful stuff, good fiction
or useful nonfiction, you are going to be
learning so much more than the average person
who's reading no books, no books at all.
I used to have a sort of like a minimum.
I wanted to read 25 nonfiction pages a day
and then some fiction at night before going
to bed.
I've recently up to 30 pages a day of nonfiction.
If I'm reading 80 books a year or whatever
it ends up working out to be and someone else
is reading Zero.
That's an insane leg up.
Whether I'm interviewing for a job or just
for personal enlightenment and knowledge,
or being an interesting person with things
to talk about.
If I'm reading 80 books and you aren't reading
any, that's going to create a big, big gap
in enjoyment, in knowledge in all of these
different things.
That's the that's my list.
And again, I'm not a self-help guy.
Is there anything magical about 8000 steps?
I don't know.
Is there anything magical about 30 grams of
fiber?
I think that's what's recommended, maybe for
men and for women, it's a little bit less.
I don't think any of these things are magic,
but they're just the things I've found that
are really useful to me.
And almost anyone can do them with relatively
little struggle.
Let me know your thoughts.
That's probably the only self-help type segment
we're going to get on the show for a while.